maintenant on va revenir sur un truc
vraiment images ou lit vraiment qui m'a
dévasté
c'est mélissa mehdi ça c'est une fan de
tpm p elle était venue le jour où
christian quesada est invité dans
l'émission les mêmes montés en loge on a
fait des photos ensemble et très vite
j'ai vu des fans qui m'écrivent et qui
misait cyril est ce que tu as eue
mélissa cyril est ce que mélissa nous a
parlé et la production a contacté
mélissa elle leur a raconté son histoire
et son histoire va nous la raconter dans
un instant et je vous le dis franchement
c'est une histoire qui m'a qui m'a
retourné en garde et voilà on était dans
ma loge me rappelle le jour elle est
venue c'est une vieille fille que j'aime
énormément
sachez qu'elle est très émue de venir ce
soir elle voulait absolument témoigner
parce que voilà et elle porte salle on a
parlé avec plein d'autres fans de doter
pmp et christian quesada s'est servi
voilà deux tpp de l'émission pour
attirer mais licha a va nous raconter
tout ça dans un instant elle a déposé
plainte en octobre dernier
on vous a résumé les faits et juste
après mélissa sera avec nous regarde
c'est une nouvelle révélation exclusive
concernant la sphère quesada ce soir
mélissa une jeunes téléspectatrices de
tpm pays sort de son silence pour
dénoncer à son tour les agissements du
maître de midi tout commence en 2017
mélissa grande fan de télévision entre
en contact avec les sur quesada et très
vite les échanges dérape
j'avais suivi christian quesada à la
télé quand il passait dans les deux
coups de midi je l'avais contacté en
janvier 2017
il m'avait envoyé un message disant
ouais il fait chaud mélissa et ils
avaient joint une photo de ses parties
génitales et de ses jambes
gêné mélissa poursuit sa conversation
avec christian quesada et lui fait part
de son rêve de venir assister à touche
pas à mon poste je lui ai dit que je
rêvé d'assister à une émission de
télévision à paris il m'a répondu qu on
dormirait ensemble à l'hôtel j'avais
répondu oui vu qu'ils me paient tous je
lui avais envoyé un message disant que
ça me gênait de dormir avec lui il m'a
répondu
je paye tous fait un effort mais il a
quelques jours plus tard l'homme
l'aurait fait venir dans sa chambre
d'hôtel à ce moment là il se serait
allongée sur le lit et lui aurait
demandé de la rejoindre tout en restant
habillé christian quesada aurait tenté
d'embrasser la jeune femme à plusieurs
reprises un acte qu'elle aurait refusé
avant de fondre en larmes
christian quesada aurait également tenté
à plusieurs reprises d'embrasser la
jeune femme dans le cou avant de la
raccompagner à la gare ce soir mélissa
accepté de venir en plateau pour nous
raconter l'histoire dont elle dit être
victime
mélissa à 20 ans elle est avec nous mais
lis ça je suis très content que tu sois
là voilà et tu sais qu'on t'aime très
fort je sais on s'était rencontrés quand
on était venu avec question à l'époque
avec christian quesada a déposé plainte
le 1er octobre 2018 contre christian
quesada pour agression sexuelle alors
déjà je voulais dire c'est vrai que
j'étais très fan de tps était content de
les voir tous un intérêt ouais même
matthieu delormeau
ça va ça va papa de padoue sur mathieu
mais je comprends je suis un peu de
détendre me dis ça parce qu'aller est
salée panique être un gros business et
bien avec nous alors le bien fort depuis
deux mois vernon non pas du tout on
regarde qui l'a peut être aidé at home
déco inquiète pas qu'à lui est ce que tu
as déjà vu stressé suis là bas donc ne
stresse pas avec nous on t'aime fort et
vraiment on est on est là pour toi et je
te dis j avais un souvenir de toi parce
qu'on était venu dans ma loge avec
christian quesada à la fin de l'émission
et on allait faire selphy ensemble on
avait un peu discuté et ces voix là je
suis très content que tu sois là
franchement voilà et les joueuses voilà
je sais que tu voulais nous parler de
ton histoire c'est en a parlé à plein
d'autres
d'autres fans de l'émission avant de
m'en parler et avant de venir nous en
parler tu t'es confié à plein de fans
jouent ce jeu c'est ouais moi j'ai mes
dit ça je te dis si tu si c'est parce
que je vois là je suis j'ai pas j'ai pas
envie de te mettre voilà dans l'embarras
tout ça je sais que tu voulais
absolument venir en parler sur le
plateau ce soir
mais voilà si tu le sens pas tes nous
c'est là nul au chaud ici on peut
annuler toutes les séquences en
préférant parler je pense que c'est de
ça même libéré et le fait de faire un
témoignage ce soir je pense protéger les
autres jeunes filles en parler de ce qui
m'est arrivé pour protéger les autres
surtout que j'applique l'avait fait ça
des mineurs donc ça m'a encore plus
traumatisée qui face à des mineurs moi
je venais tout juste d'avoir 17 ans
quand les faits se sont passés donc
c'est ça tu venais de dieu n'est d'avoir
d'autres 17 ans ils n'ont pas 18 ans 18
18 ans tu avais 18 ans c'était en mars
2010 est ton rêve c'était d'assister à
touche pas à mon poste c'est pour ça
qu'on en parle ce soir parce que voilà
ce témoignage est gelée vu passer voilà
sur les réseaux sociaux un moment j'ai
dit oh on va parler à mélissa christan
donc taquin que quesada tu as organisé
et payé le voyage alors qu'il était
invité sur le plateau
ils ont rappelé la production même pour
passer dans les coulisses d'ailleurs
puisque tu es venu me voir après t'as vu
toute l'équipe dans les coulisses c'est
un plaisir pour moi voilà de te recevoir
comment tu as commencé à parler avec
christian parce que moi je te dis la
vérité quand je t'ai vu arriver dans la
loge j'étais persuadé que vous étiez
hyper potes depuis père longtemps donc
je me suis dit bon ben je te reçois avec
lui j'ai pas su mobiliser ses potes je
savais pas que vous connaissiez très peu
voilà j'ai fait des décennies avec toi
on a parlé un petit peu
il m'a raconté un petit peu ces projets
voilà moi et et quand j'ai appris ça
après je me suis limite je m'en suis
voulu parce que je me suis peut-être que
j'aurais dit peut-être plus lui parler
pour savoir que voilà ce qu'elle est ce
qu'elle faisait avec christian tout ça
mais j'ai pas voulu rentrer là-dedans
l'outil bon c'est vrai que après audi on
aurait peut-être pu intervenir
alors voila mais voilà et je m'en suis
voulu et donc comment tu as commencé à
parler avec avec son parcours en janvier
2010 est ce que tu es fan de télé dont
tu le suivait dans les douves voilà j'ai
vu féliciter m'avait répondu en juin
2009 17 et il m'a dit merci et c'est le
jeu que je sais qu'il était invité dans
l'émission avec jean luc reichmann
il dit que j'étais fan de tpm paix que
c'était mon rêve de venir vous voir
il a dit si tu veux que j'appelle le
producteur et tu viens dès demain il y
aura une place dans le public
et du coup il m'a dit ça il m'a dit je
te paie tout de a à z train hôtel la
nourriture bas au départ c'est
franchement c'est hyper jours aux années
on se dit c'est sympa de faire ça voilà
là on le fait pour des fans d'ouvriers
ou parfois voilà qui a envie de venir
qui ont pas les moyens de payer ou pas
et est donc la toile un mois une mineure
avec un parc ou et bien sûr il faut se
méfier dans tous les cas parce que là
c'était lui c'était pas la production
qui allait payer
c'est ça mais bon après faut hélas pour
les filles oui c'est sur lui et mélissa
après moi je te dis moi je suis moi
franchement je comprend elle s'est dit
voilà il m'invite je suis à la
production des ppp qu'est ce qui va
m'arriver particulièrement tout à fait
et je comprends que je suis très content
tu soignes
alors on a vu qu'il a envoyé des photos
intimes a beaucoup de jeunes filles est
ce que ça a été aussi le cas pour toi ou
pas du tout
ça m'a traumatisé du coup j'ai tout
supprimer c'était avant ou après ton
d'état venus danser avant avant d'accord
avait envoyé une photo de ces gens mieux
avec une photo d'une partie de ses
photos de ces partis mais il avait un
caleçon d'accord alors donc après il
s'est calmé et tu t'es dit bon voilà ils
m'invitent atp dur je vais être sur le
plateau etc vous avez la boule au ventre
dans le public j'étais content de vous
voir mais j'avais la boule au ventre le
fait que je vais le revoir après away
pourquoi alors j'étais content de vous
voir sur le fait bien sûr mais pendant
l'émission fait à christian et ma mère
sur notre téléphone et même a bien dit
que ma fille était pas venu pour ça que
je devais dormir tout seul le soir dans
l'hôtel battu mieux dormir dans le même
lit que moi dans l'hôtel et je pense que
ça aurait été plus loin
fiche alors à vous êtes arrivé à paris
et à ton arrivée à paris vous allez dans
un bar et a offert un verre c'est ça et
il a commencé est une cuma dit tu as dit
la production qu'il a commencé à toucher
les cuisses a touché les mains n'a
touché les routes des cuisses tout le
monde me regarder bizarrement dans le
bas-rhin de liens mais qu'est-ce qui
fait cette jeune fille fait personne n'a
interpellé fin même les boeufs les
serveurs l'abeille regardé bizarrement
donc d'après tap tap au tas poser
l'arrêter maj est pas aussi enfin
quand il ya un truc dommage mais enfin
je sais pas j'ai fais pas dire les
choses et et m'ont dit vous êtes allé
dans la chambre d'hôtel
ce kit avarie tu avais invité à venir il
s'est allongé sur le lit et qui t'a dit
donc de venir à côté de moi je sais pas
trop d'aléas côté de nuit allongés et là
il commence à faire des bisous sur la
bouche donc choqué au bout de cinq
minutes je mets ma main devant la bouche
et heureusement de lever la main pour me
refaire des bijoux du coup sur le coup
je me mets à pleurer je me suis retrouvé
renée du coffret à l'opposé de lui ai
dit ouais t'as pas de quoi pleurer tu te
sens en sécurité avec moi tu va réaliser
ton rêve tu va retirer les kamis van
damme était d'utiliser douche en
sécurité fin il en train de me violer
j'étais en plein et tu te sens en
sécurité avec moi t'as pas de quoi
pleurer tu va réaliser ton rêve
oui je pense qu'il a profité de ma
confiance pour en arriver là
dans témoignages on le voit c'est
incroyable et moi quand j'ai appris
c'est que tu étais venu vraiment pour
nous voir et que ça se passe comme ça je
vous dis moi c'est un cauchemar pour les
personnes qui qui sont ici je vous dit
on à un moment s'est demandé si on
allait faire le témoignage de mme ellis
island et le derrière ou la moelle a
même annulé
et oui ça elle voulait absolument parler
parce que mélissa que je sais que tu te
sens très très mal depuis depuis ce
triste jour os et en octobre dernier
tu nous a dit voilà je vous en parlais
je pense que ça va me libérer que je
pouvoir après j'espère passer à autre
chose
ensuite vous êtes venus ici tu as envoyé
des sms à ta mère quand vous étiez dans
le métro au bout de dix ou si ça m'a
appelé parce que je ne faisais pas
répondre devant question vous voulez
dire ma mère j'ai peur je m'inquiète en
plus à l'époque fin à deux ans je
connaissais pas paris mais j'aurai connu
parmi je me serais paraît depuis
longtemps enfin même le soir mais la
compagnie ajoute elle voulait pas rester
à l'hôtel
je voulais partir mais du comment
ensuite tu tapes et amer donc pour lui
dire que tu avais tu avais peur
j'ai peur qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ensuite quand vous êtes venu à
l'émission parce que quand je vous ai
vue après dans les loges
vous aviez dire voilà je sais pas moi
j'ai peut-être pas pas su voir les
choses mais j'ai pas vu voilà qui avait
il y avait un malaise ou quelque chose
tu as essayé de faire bonne figure
devant moi devant devant les âges
étaient contents de devoir de faire une
photo avec toi mais après c'est gt1
j'avais un peu la boule au ventre
de fait de moi je suis venu à paris pour
passer une bonne un bon moment et là je
vois que je suis tombé sur un pédophile
alors bien sûr tout ça ces présumés bien
sûr ccco bien sûr il ya le camp la
présomption d'innocence il ya le
témoignage voilà de 2010 à voilà qui
nous glace tout ça on le voit et eilat
avait elle avait 18 ans donc mélissa
c'était c'était c'était il ya un an tout
juste
donc c'est vrai que c'est pas de la
pédophilie nom puisqu'elle avait 18 ans
mais une fois terminée la vie de
faiblesse sévèrement de l'abus de
faiblesse
exactement ce qu'elle est désolée n'ose
pas s'exprimer elle n'ose pas dire il
voit qu'elle pleure et malgré tout ils
continuent
je pense que quand elle vous a vu à la
fin un espèce de déni je pense que son
cerveau ses protégés de ce qu'il ne lui
arrivait elle était choquée à la fin
d'année elle a profité de l'instant
présent ça bienvenu après je pense alors
oui j'aime chez les cycles et les
personnes comme comme chris tongs et
céda profite aux débuts de l'admiration
la fascination qu'ont les fans
voilà pour essayer d attirer dans leurs
filets et après profil d'un manque de
sidération c'est que les gens qui sont
après sont victimes comme ça ne peuvent
pas réagir ne savent pas comment réagir
et du coup ils profitent de cette
faiblesse là pour continuer à agir alors
qu'on pourrait dire mais pourquoi t'es
pas partie et c'est parce que les gens
sont sidérés c'est un phénomène qui est
très connu par ailleurs ne sais pas
comment alors mélissa la question que
tout ce monde se pose c'est ensuite donc
quand l'émission s'est terminée quand tu
es partie de la loge parce qu'on a on a
passé un petit moment ensemble à
discuter
voilà parce que bon c'est vrai que moi
aussi je me doutais pas que christian
quesada était
peyremale annonce qu'on présume
hirsonnais voilà comment on parle
qu'est ce que tu as fait après tu t'es
tu vous êtes rentrer ensemble où tu l'as
dit à l'hôtel comment vous vous parliez
vous du tout je n'osais même pu lui
parler qu'est ce que tu as fait tu as
dormi tout seul tu as pu dormir tout à
fait pu dormir tout seul mais c'était
dur j'ai passé une sale nuit et enfin
c'était très dur et après au bout on y
rentre à l'hôtel il est resté cinq
minutes après il est reparti et le
lendemain matin il est venu me chercher
à l'hôtel et on a raccompagné à la gare
montparnasse pour aller prendre mon
train du retour mais il ya eu il ya il
n'a pas essayé à autre chose le
lendemain matin il m'a fait un bisou
mais dans la nuque d'accord en cherchant
donc d'accord et le soir i
je sais qu'il avait eu ta maman
téléphone qu'est ce que t'es pas ce que
tu avais prévenus ta maman avant qu il
au téléphone tu lui a dit qu'il avait un
comportement pas ami justin maintenant
j'ai peur je suis en pleurs et du coup
il avoué il a par latéralement il lui a
dit quoi ta maman du touch qui se sont
tu vas j'avais demandé à ta maman mais
ils m'ont amené à visiter que j'ai juste
dit que tu étais pas venu pour ça et
qu'il ne fallait pas qu'ils dorment avec
toi à l'hôtel bien sûr et vous a pas dit
suivait bah oui c'est ce que je peux lui
poser une question aux sirènes qui
assure mathieu juste et aucun aucun
jugement juste comment votre maman entre
guillemets que plus âgée que vous aimez
vous a laissé dormir dans une chambre
d'hôtel avec monsieur beaucoup plus âgé
au début mes parents - deux chambres
peut-être non retenu mais prendre en
hindi va pas avec un mec plus sage et
one n'y va pas vu que je voulais à tout
prix à la tpp j'ai pas réfléchi je suis
parti à l'avant elle a 18 ans c'est
compliqué en tant que parent non
monsieur sam hamad un tas du rallye
d'automne s'est impliqué en tant que
parent quand tu sais que ta fille elle
va réaliser son rêve tous les jours et
sans la télé tous les jours elle est en
train de et camille et cyril et jean
michel valet ils font partie de la
famille parce que vous vous êtes dedans
vous rendez pas compte mais tp vous
faites partie de la famille des gens il
se dépêche pour rentrer plus vite etc
etc
là il fait et ce qu'il fait et ce qu'il
fait et christian quesada ils profitent
ils profitent sur sa passion il a joué
sur sa passion pour la faire venir moi
je vais te faire rencontrer les gars
mais je vais à l'émission c'est quoi
la moment si elle lui dit vas-y pas
après la sa fille qui va lui faire la
gueule pendant des années des années
des fois tu dis bon bah faut laisser le
destin faire elle a 17 ans elle a 18 ans
elle est grande elle va y aller six
autres c'est la volonté de pas faire de
scandale je suppose c'est très serré
fort se sentent la sueur csssae et et
mélissa depuis quand tu as vu tout ce
qui arrive est au tour de christian
quesada qu'est ce que tu t'es dit ça m'a
choqué même s'il fait un jamie du temps
allait porter plainte j'ai mis un an et
demi m en aller porter plainte c'est ça
ta tête bien non il n'y allait porter
plainte parce que j'avais peur que
personne ne croit que le fait qu'il soit
connu ouais mais ça tu racontes
n'importe quoi mais c'est ça elle a
raison parce que quand vous êtes rentré
mine de rien avec votre maman vous en
avez paris ou pas j'ai mis du temps
parce que notre maman comme vous l'aviez
appelez vous lui avez dit que vous aviez
peur un moment quand vous êtes rentrée
elle vous a dit qu'il s'était pas dit
qu'est ce qui s'est passé parler de a à
z
c'était compliqué de pour moi d'en
parler vous avez à votre maman ça était
voilà j'ai eu peur j'ai pas aimé il
était sous l'eau mais sans puisse écrire
puisque à la basse amenant veux pas
qu'elle y aille havas par l'entrée en
disant tu as vers le sarment ça s'est
passé elle a fermé
c'est un vraiment londres- nasrallah et
après vous vous étiez piéger en fait
c'est ça et vous en avez parlé à votre
maman quoi un an et demi après 1 au bout
de d'un mois au bout a mis du temps
enfin j'ai pas tout dit de zazen mais je
suis suivi psychologiquement par rapport
à ce qu'il m'est arrivé à christian
depuis ce qui m'a écrit sans ça m'a
tellement traumatisée que je suis
psychologue c'est si si c'est fou parce
que je vous dis je je repense à ça parce
que je pense vraiment ce moment que j'ai
passé avec avec mélissa dans les loges
vraiment et je vous le dis moi j'étais
persuadé que vous étiez franchement vous
étiez potes comme il m'a dit voilà je
suis mais konami mais dis ça je me suis
dit bon c'est vrai des beaucoup plus
jeunes que lui mais voilà résister en
parler
je me suis dit est-ce que cyril even
croit le fait que je veux en parler tout
fin j'avais peur que bien sûr c'est la
voix d'une jeune fille colère des gens
qui sont connues et célèbre personne va
nous croire et c'est vrai que cette
jeune fille est vraiment je te souhaite
le meilleur parce que derrière tu devais
être là dès qu'on te prend dans ses bras
aujourd'hui même juste pour te faire un
bisou quoi tu trembles complètement
comme cessé mais peut-être ccc il faut
pas faire n'importe quoi les jeunes
filles qui nous regardent pour aller
voir cyril hanouna pour venir ici ne
faut pas faire n'importe quoi il faut
rester vraiment l'un des axes et vous
verrez des gens comme ça qui vous font
faire n'importe quoi je vais te payer
ceci je vais payer mais il ya quelque
chose derrière
même le fait qu'ils la raccompagne le
lendemain il vient la recherché par
accompagne la gare montparnasse c'est
qu'ils savaient qu'il avait peut-être
c'est une connerie déjà suivi parce
qu'elle tremble beaucoup et dont on voit
qu'elle est très très très affecté je
les rencontre des lycées
je veux dire j'aurais aimé que c'est
devenu athée pmp soit un bon souvenir
pour toi j'étais contente de vous voir
oui mais après j'ai la boule au ventre
pas de revenir sur la prochaine fois tu
me dirait une ville
l'invité et c'est vrai que je joue
vraiment je regrette pressé c'est vrai
que jo je regrette et se retourne se
posent des questions après je me dis
peut-être que j'aurais dû c'est pas non
plus avec toi avec avec lui pour savoir
si vous parlez de l'emprise vois tu vois
aujourd'hui j'imagine ta photo tous les
trois bien sûr elle a franchement cette
annonce soit licite à chaque imprimante
en loge les gens devant les studios tu
vas pas dire à chaque fois l'or à temps
il faut qu'on parle moi tu connais dit
ou tu connais d'astreinte carte vitale
de tout le monde elle arrive vite à
apporter tout son nom tu dis bonjour tu
fais ton selphy tu es content tu viens à
un moment tu donne du plaisir aux gens
et basta tu veux faire dos tu vas pas
dire aux gens venez on va tous mangé
j'ai besoin de savoir qui fait quoi
maintenant je peux pas l'impossible
souhaite dire déjà merci parce que
beaucoup de courage et à la vie
jusqu'où ça est ce que est ce que tu te
sens mieux déjà que c'est vrai moi
serait fait le fait d'en parler sur le
plateau ça me déstresse pour pourquoi
pas ce que tu es c'est ainsi le fait de
revenir élective peut-être ça les
vaincus 7 permet d'évacuer et c'est dur
pour moi d'en parler ce sans fin les
images et reviennent c'est dur enfin
j'ai voulu témoigner ce soir pour me
libérer mais c'est dur on en parle et ça
va marcher et à partir pour toi je suis
sûr que ça va marcher
et tu sais que vraiment je ne dis pas ça
pour voilà pour dire un truc en l'air tu
sais que ici on sera toujours avec toi
tu sais que voilà et j'ai vu et je
voudrais dire aussi merci à toutes les
personnes qui suivent tpb qui sont venus
vraiment en aide à mélissa qui ont
beaucoup parlé sur les réseaux je crois
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont venus
en aide qui sont quittes on dit même il
faut que tant par la syrie une feinte de
vue ce qui vous a contacté le sait et il
a dit v syrie ni répond souvent mmp mais
je pense qu'il le verra et fille de
loewe il trompait ctera voilà et c'est
vrai que merci à vous parce que c'est
vrai que c'est une vraie famille aussi
touche pas à mon poste est vraiment je
te dis et la prochaine fois si tu veux
aller sur d'autres émissions tu nous
demandes et laura va de 6 jours être
faire un gros bisou
[Applaudissements]